with Parliament deadlocked people are
dividing into camps but within this
tribal atmosphere we're on the hunt for
compromise and we find people from rival
March to agree a solution on bricks
we're going to remain we're going to
remain it was thirteen years ago that
David Cameron told the Conservatives to
stop banging on about Europe but rather
than contained the argument it has
exploded what once divided a political
party now divides the country there have
been two marches one last Saturday which
attracted hundreds of thousands the
other began two weeks ago in Sunderland
on route to London with a very different
message they think they can walk all
over us well we well we're gonna march
back to them
[Music]
in the thick of these protests are to
ordinary individuals from different
camps for whom brexit has hijacked their
lives we're going to get to know them
then bring them together to thrash out a
compliment let's start with Mandy former
NHS health trainer from the West
Midlands now semi-retired who has joined
the leave means leave much Sunderland
with the guys and I think so how are
your feet fights or kick to be the
pedicure when I went into the vote
voting booths and I put my ex on that
ballot paper I actually not naively
accepting in voting since I was 18 I
thought that love the Lancaster's house
speech that we've got it she's got it
she knows what she's doing
few weeks later it's just gone from I
said to Dana male journalist which came
up to me should be marching with us all
day talking to people especially I Astro
says have you found any
I said those racists and bigots and
those uneducated people that was this
favor she says no Everett and that's
what the truth and that's what's been so
painful outside the London bubble you
don't have to see they're cold
about comparing us to Hitler you know
that we vote 17 million people voted for
Hitler in 1933 that was a black art and
I personally have been trolled and
they've called with fewer mustache on me
and it's do you know and it's quite
painful action and it's quite bizarre
and I think someone I'm far right now
and leaders of far-right you know and we
can't understand it's not breaking
actually why people think of us that way
ok let's go to the other camp will dry
actually voted leave when he was just a
teeny now campaigns for a people's vote
and wants to remain in the EU I went to
Oxford to study PPA which is politics I
paused the university like came out to
help set up youth group a few drug
choice which was a group of young people
who campaigning for people so you've
left your studies you put them on hold
yes yeah to do this yeah this is kind of
like taking over your life and yeah
definitely and and the weird thing is
yeah the weird thing is taking over your
life because you were actually
campaigning against the way which you
voted yeah is slightly weird when you
think about it when did you start to
think this is necessarily
if there was one moment it was that time
where David Davis went in a go shaped
like the first time and the Europeans
have like piles of papers and we're
looking really focused and he kind of
just sat there like a lad with no papers
just smiling at the camera and I just
saw that I mean obviously that photo
didn't really influence me but I do
think looking back it was kind of
symbolic of how the negotiations were to
go I certainly didn't vote and I hope
nobody did in 2016 for for a kind of 16%
hit to the Northeast economy for a huge
disruption along our trade routes or
chaos along with Northern Irish board
which No Deal would create I mean Boris
Johnson said a week before the
referendum for anybody who talked about
No Deal was insane now he was the kind
of lead spokesperson for vote leave
campaign if he's saying that I don't
think you can interpret the referendum
result as a mandate for for No Deal but
back at the brexit March in Northampton
that's exactly what they're saying
outrageous president democracy is
massively under threat we plain
politicians for not being able to you
know come to an agreement come to a deal
do you really think if we sat the entire
population of the country in the House
of Commons they'd be able to come up
with a cure until everybody said watch
see is that you know the most number of
votes wins that's how it works and
people were given that vote and we were
told we were told by the government that
they would carry out our instruction my
question wasn't it it wasn't leave
subject to the terms and conditions it
was leave that was what was on the
ballot paper okay that's what people
voted for so which version of brexit did
people vote for it was it Michael Gove
Zoar Boris Johnson's because they bear
two leaders of the campaign and they
both taken different stances everybody
had lots of reasons for voting brixon
but the question was remain or leave
what are the people vote for Shane makes
a difference walking I know that people
say I suppose it's like there remain is
more oh it doesn't make any difference
you know but the thing is those marches
in the past did make a difference you
know
suffragettes they did get the vote and
things like this it's not just about oh
you won't make a difference we already
have made a difference what people say
to me you know I'm so fed up but at
least I feel like I'm doing something
I'm not it's this sense of powerlessness
against a total elite if our vote
doesn't mean anything anymore
the people on this much trust me they do
know that we're a great country and so
do you really don't you great but
divided the scale of people holding the
opposite view was demonstrated last
Saturday hundreds of thousands took to
the streets calling for a second
referendum the march on this scale
hasn't been seen since the 2003 protest
against the Iraq war and they're just as
passionate this shows that there is a
groundswell towards remain or is this
just a group of people who voted remain
who didn't like the result I think it's
going to be a group of people who didn't
like the result but as I said in my sort
of little comments on the stage for me
this is about the people whose will is
being obeyed and the long list of things
they were told that have turned out
simply not to be true they told us we
could leave the EU
[Music]
[Applause]
and behind the scenes helping to
organize all of this is our lever turned
remainer
do you think you can make any difference
what happens when a million people take
to the streets because they're so
frustrated and when millions it is
absolutely puts enormous pressure on
politicians to realize what they're
doing is not heading down the right path
they're not heading down the path that
the people want them to head down I
think this is going to end just
ingredient just said with a referendum
because it can only go back to the
people to solve it so let's bring our
two protagonists together so great to
get you both together but we're not here
for a fight yeah
just soul breaks it okay I'll start with
you will is there any form of brexit
that you can accept I think if the
country voted for a brexit deal in full
knowledge of what it precisely entailed
because it was a credible plan that was
on the ballot paper and a majority vote
for I would 100% exact that will saying
some kind of ratification of whatever we
end up with why how do you feel about
that well the ratification for me was
the actual vote in the beginning and all
this we didn't know what we voted for we
actually did well I understand maybe in
other people's vote in a few years time
but not now we haven't okay so could you
accept their people's vote down the line
but I would agree very like the most
sensible way to do it would be to get
rid of transition period and and and to
negotiate the future agreement during
that period and then put that to the
people once we actually know what it is
at the end but that's not a situation
where it no no but if it was I hope we
can rally around you could could you
rally around that so let's forget the
transition period yeah I just think no I
mean Houston says we do want to
compromise but if if an let's face it
let's get this one out the way if remain
had one we would not be sitting in a
hark we would not be discussing anything
about oh we can't do this we can't it it
would have been subtle because we
wouldn't be an enough process but we
only international crisis work because
those in Parliament we've got to remain
Prime Minister most opponents remain
most of the establishment is remaining
and they don't want it and you can see
what they've done a huge we disagree on
the kind of democratic side of the
argument it's not I don't think they're
seventeen point four million people
voted for no deal if you look at
everything that vote Lee said leave you
said the two main campaign groups they
were both arguing with we're going to
leave with a deal not just a dough but a
deal better than one we've currently got
and and giving them that hasn't been
negotiated I think it's a democratic
right to be able to compare all the
options but there were too many people
in Parliament who didn't want that will
they didn't want
Rexie and they were going to try any way
they could to stop Breck see and that's
what people have seen would you accept
that there there's been quite a large
number of people in Parliament who've
seen this as a damage limitation
exercise yes absolutely so you kind of
agree with that point yeah and and
therefore you possibly have great
respect for just the straight out
argument then any other yeah I maybe I
maybe do in an odd way because I think
with those people at least think that
what they're arguing for will benefit
the country to reason they knows but
what she's arguing for won't benefit the
country and that was pretty much the
only thing they agreed on two resumes
Beall isn't the answer we're try
so here we are the pro brexit March
finally reached Parliament Square
swelling to several thousand in number
the debate is more polarized than ever
if there was a middle ground it's
currently lost somewhere in a sea of
protests
Jason Farrell Sky News